the administration also facing backlash
after stopping border wall construction
here while spending millions of dollars
to protect borders of other countries
watch
the Omnibus last year provides for at
least 150 million dollars for border
security in Jordan it's a large amount
of taxpayer dollars and if you think
about the purpose of this
is to provide physical security to keep
people from illegally crossing into
Jordan isn't that correct
it is to provide physical security to
stop drug smugglers to deal with the
threat of
Jordan's neighbor Syria
obviously the conflict there continues
and it's a it's a dangerous neighborhood
I mean just you could say the same exact
thing about our relationship with the
cartels in Mexico Monica Crowley served
as assistant treasury secretary under
former president Trump and joins us now
Monica great to see you great to see you
too it is staggering if you if if that
official was asked the same question
about our Southern border the answer
would be entirely different and it's our
country well this is what you get with
America last right we had four years of
America First under President Trump and
now under President Biden we've got
America last it shows you where this
administration's priorities are as well
as the priorities of all of these
Sanctuary cities like this city that's
canceling this private wedding to make
room for migrants coming in it shows you
their economic priorities but also their
overall political priorities as well so
this Administration has no problem
spending upwards of 200 billion dollars
to help enforce Ukraine's border from an
Invasion From Russia okay and now we've
got uh this woman who is coming in to be
ambassador to Jordan who also has no
problem flagging 150 billion dollars
excuse me 150 million dollars to help
enforce Jordan's border from what from
illegal immigration possible drug and
human trafficking and National Security
threats right well what are we facing on
our Southern border all of those things
and more so again it's about
prioritizing other countries physical
barriers helping them enforce their
borders and enforcing their sovereignty
but when it comes to the United States
and protecting our interests and our
people they want no part of that well
Monica it's almost like they not only do
they want no part of it they want it to
be open of course they're actually
leading the charge on the facilitation
of as many people as possible coming
into our country well that's it and
everybody has to understand that this is
a deliberate act on the part of the
Biden Administration this is not
incompetence this is not some sort of
bungling effort by secretary mayorkas
this is an intentional flooding of the
United States of America if they wanted
to change course by now they would have
just out of like sheer desire for
political survival for Biden and his
party they have not done that so that
tells you exactly what their intentions
are it's about flooding the United
States with illegal immigrants it's
about ultimately getting them on a track
for full citizenship and voting so that
the Democrats have a permanent Democrat
voting majority it's about flipping the
demographics and the fundamental
transformation of the nation that's why
I suggest we just hand them a ballot at
the border make it a lot more efficient
well we are we're giving them cell
phones now anyway Pete and and just like
automatic uh court dates and everything
else they don't even have to show their
face until 2027. it's incredible well
it's great to see you you summed it up
well I said how you doing he said I'm
great except for everything except for
the state of the country for a lot of
people I'm fine but I appreciate it and
Happy Mother's Day to my fantastic mom
Pat and to Rachel is on set somewhere
else Rachel and to all the other super
moms out there happy Mother's Day you
got it thank you Monica thanks Pete I'm
Steve Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade and I'm
Ainsley Earhart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis